hello my name is Eric weisstein I work
at Wolfram research I'm going to be
speaking today on the 2019 SI system of
units which redefined units used by most
countries in the world and implications
that was had for the unit and quantity
systems in Mathematica and Wolfram Alpha
thank you all for coming this afternoon
my name is Eric weisstein I've been at
Wolfram for more than 20 years and
worked on a number of different projects
today I have the honor and privilege of
talking about one that came out of one
of the pieces of work I do on Wolfram
Alpha which is the unit system and there
was something very interesting and
fundamental that happened in the world
of units earlier this year but most
people didn't notice so it turns I have
used Mathematica you might have noticed
because we accommodated these
fundamental changes and today I want to
try to explain a little bit about what
happens why it's interesting why it's
important and just assure you that
Mathematica has the best way to compute
anything as precisely correctly as
possible is now completely up to date
with the correct way to measure units
used by all countries in the world
except a few minor exceptions that need
not be mentioned like ours so anyway I
made 20th of this year there were four
base units in the SI system of units
that were redefined and they were
redefined by basically setting four
fundamental constants from physics to
exact values previously they had been
measured when expressed in terms of SI
units the change was they were defined
in terms of these physical constants and
this means that in addition to three of
the seven which had definitions you know
the speed of light was exact a couple
other I'll show you later that means all
SI units are now defined in terms of
physical constants of nature that are
universal don't change over time and can
be measured in any lab not on some bar
sitting in a vault in Paris somewhere so
the goal of one of the goals of the
changes was not to make any difference
to people who use units so the new
values that were chosen are
indistinguishable for all practical
purposes from the old ones so you think
okay then why does it matter well it
matters because
the Wolfram language and Wolfram Alpha
treat things exactly and we need to know
is something an exact number is an
approximate same thing for physical
constants so all discuss a little bit in
detail about what those things all mean
so in order to before we get to units I
want to talk a little bit about physical
constants since this is now how units
are defined and in fact US units are now
defined in terms of these physical
constants now because US units are
defined in terms of SI units so it
actually effectively redefined the u.s.
units a little bit too but again to an
imperceptible amount so as of version 12
we added a new entity domain knowing
that this SI thing was coming because it
had been under discussion for many years
so we have a physical content constant
entity domain in which we attempt to
curate and collect and these things were
us were even nicely documented starting
some of these entities existed before
this is a new one but all of these if
you haven't seen these entity pages
before now have nicely detailed pages so
if you know about entities but we're
afraid to ask or didn't know how to use
them look them up in the help browser
and you'll find all sorts of details and
useful information about them so we
added this physical constant domain and
as of right now we have about 287
physical constants in it here's an
example of some of them that probably
too small to see but they include
cosmological things include you know
your old friends speed of light Planck's
constant and they have various
properties associated with them so let's
just take for an example the
gravitational constant which it turns
out is one of the least well-known so if
you ask for this the physical constant
entity corresponding to the
gravitational constant we give you the
value that value has in this case you
can see it's coming back there's a back
tick here I don't know if you in the
back can see but it's a precision tag
number so this represents the best
experimental uncertainty of this number
and this is one that was was not
redefined exactly in terms of SI units
okay so if I asked for the precision
there we go it's known to about 4.3
digits
I can do things like try to ask about
the uncertainty in different forms we
have this beautiful new around construct
so it will say it's this number plus or
minus this number and you can also get
it back in other forms such as an
interval precision whatever okay so with
most physical constants the accuracy
with of the precision they can be
measured with increases over time and
it's useful for some people for some
applications to actually be able to keep
track of you know how was what was the
best known value of this ten years ago
or twelve years ago because some of the
international bodies actually define
things in terms of the best value was
measured ten years ago so it turns out
that the physical constant domain
defines not only the best value today
but you can see here we have code data
from 2010 code data from 2006 so we have
a historical record of the best values
that these constants are known to maybe
not going back to the beginning of time
but as far as I've gotten back to
curating them yet and you can do nice
things like you can plot them here I'm
just creating a table of pulling out the
values for the gravitational constant
and you can see that one has big error
bars on it that one's still hard to
measure so that would not be a good one
to base your definition of the SI system
on because we really don't know it very
well but it turns out a couple of and
just seeing a little bit more about
physical constants where do the best
values come from well there you know
domain-specific standards body like the
international astronomical unit their
geodesy bodies that define you know
defining ellipses of the earth there's
Planck collaboration has a good
collection of cosmology related
constants from the Planck satellite the
particle data people you know have their
own best measured values people publish
papers where they measure once but one
of the best most widely used and most
standard one is called Co data and that
is
a group of people established back in
1966 who has a special task force to
comb through the literature and
basically find the best values figure
out their correlations and and publish
standard values that you should use when
you use these in calculations so for
instance you know it can search for
electron mass here and this is updated
every four years
these are all the constants I know you
can't read them there's the electron
mass and here's the value that it says
it thinks you should use so every four
years we have to update physical
constant to do that to include those new
values okay so where do unit definitions
come from for all the world except the
USA Mayan Mar and Liberia they come from
the SI system of units which in turn is
overseen by an international committee
with a French acronym because the French
are the ones who started this whole
process back in 1875 and they have a
special committee that meets on regular
basis to make recommendations related to
units unit measurements and they make
recommendations on periodic basis and
then they release this thing called the
SI brochure which is the the gold
standard that says how SI units are
defined how it's allowed to use them
their definitions and all those sorts of
things so this thing is published sort
of at irregular intervals the last major
one was in 2006 this one the new one in
May came out in 2019 so it's been 13
years since they really changed anything
so this is kind of a big deal in the
world of in the world of Units and the
other good thing about it is since this
change they're not going to have to
change too much again because now these
values are set in stone in terms of
fundamental things which has been a goal
of metrology for a long long time so on
May 20th the ninth edition the SI
brochure was released as I said it's the
first revision in 13 years and it
completes a process that was begun a
half-century ago when they started
moving away from the lengths of rods and
the masses of cylinders to
measuring the speed of light originally
defined in terms of vibrations of some
krypton spectral line but then through a
series of refinements they changed it to
a definition in terms of they define the
second exactly in terms of an atomic
constant related to vibrations of a
different atom and then they define the
speed of light as an exact number of
meters per second when you use define
the second in this way so they already
had okay but until this year the
kilogram was the only thing that
remained as a physical prototype so
there's some kilogram in Paris somewhere
and all the units are defined not all
the units but the kilograms and ones
defined by the kilograms depend on that
particular man-made arbitrary object so
finally that is retired that can move to
a museum somewhere they can show it to
people they don't have to keep it in a
you know noble gas archive and only show
it on special occasions and the SI as I
said at the beginning became wholly de
Rivel from natural phenomena which is it
is very desirable and as I also already
mentioned the new values were chosen so
that for all practical purposes people
who measure stuff in labs or use units
won't actually notice that they did
which most of you probably didn't so
prior to 2019 there were three of the
seven sort of fundamental SI units the
speed of light defined m/s vibration of
cesium defined basically the ii through
hertz inverse seconds there's another
one called luminous efficacy d that was
defined in terms of monochromatic
emission of monochromatic radiation now
in 2009 we covered the other four all at
once and the way they were covered is
the planck constant is exactly this
number this is no longer a measured
number with some uncertainty the planck
constant h is exactly that many joule
seconds yes sir
that's the thing it's it's chosen to
define the combination of lumens and
Watts so it defines the Candela so it
just happens it's a nice exact number
the second is a nice exact number and
the speed of light they're all integers
in order to retain compatibility with
the existing definitions based on the
kilogram and that you can see these
others are not exact integers in fact so
we have Planck constant elementary
charge Boltzmann constant and Avogadro
constant when expressed in SI units
these are now exact quantities so that
means if you measure this in your lab
the at what actually changes is not the
value in SI units but the value of the
SI unit itself so the values of these
constants in SPECT expressed in SI units
are set in stone so one side effect this
has people may have heard of base units
so kilogram meter second or considered
base units there isn't really a base you
don't need a base unit in Si anymore
because they're all expressible through
combinations of these physical constants
but they're kept around because people
are used to them and they really are the
ones that we encounter most often in
daily life as I said seven of them now
define the system they're exact one
curious side-effect is though because of
the inner relations between their many
physical constants and some are kind of
related to others in various ways for
those of you who do you know many any
sort of electromagnetic or physics
you'll know permittivity of free space
or electric constant impedance of free
space those used to be exact there are
these things like 4pi times 10 to the
minus 7 or whatever after this change
defining other constants to be exact
these are now in exact so it's kind of
counterintuitive but it follows from the
whole
sort of interconnected network of how
things are physically and in fact the
uncertainties of most physical constants
are best expressed and computed in terms
of the the other physical constants that
you can measure best in the lab which
turn out to be the fine-structure
constant which you can measure to many
many many digits and the Redbird
constant which is a spectroscopic thing
that people have been measuring for
hundreds of years and you can also get
to many digits speed of light is one of
the three that was already defined prior
to 2019 so there were three now there's
all seven and I think this will become
clear on some of my okay so what did
this mean for the Wolfram language well
obviously for physical constants which
is all I've really talked about so far
we had to add these new definitions keep
the old ones but add the new ones and
adjust all the values and uncertainties
because like Faraday's constant is
Avogadro's number times the electric
charge so that now has an exact value
when expressed in SI units so we have to
go through and basically update every
single physical constant when expressed
in terms of SI units more or less and
WolframAlpha it had a few consequences
as well the most immediate was know if
you can see this so this is probably
what you would expect to see for
Planck's constant six point six two six
times ten to the 34 plus some other
digits but the point is it's not just
some other digits now it's now an exact
rational number so poor my colleague
Jorn had to go through and make some
adjustments in order to make sure that
we can show you the exact value but we
don't give it to you by default because
most people don't want it by default or
care about it by default but as a
Mathematica user you might okay so what
does it mean that the elementary charge
is exactly this many coulombs well of
course in Mathematica that's not an
exact number when we see a decimal we
assume you have a what kind of a number
it's a machine number so what this
statement actually means in Mathematica
is I take this decimal number and I move
the desk
over nine places so it's a rational
number
so all these rational numbers with very
large numerators and denominators start
popping up and most of the world doesn't
care because all they care about is well
you know it's approximately equal to
this to that many digits but we do
things exactly so we care and as I said
this also has implications so Josephson
constant is another constant that can be
defined in terms of the elementary
charge and the Planck constant and so by
taking these other constants and putting
them together with a to e over H you
find out it has that value it and it
doesn't really matter except when it
does it matters on a sort of higher
level metrology framework it's it's the
right way to go it has some very strange
side effects but it's actually beautiful
yes yes it's theoretical metrology put
into practice yes yes exactly exactly so
okay so here here are now as physical
constant entities the new ones that are
new and old that are exact and there's
their symbols and there's their values
so but we haven't gotten to the unit's
part yet have we so what we really want
to do is now solve for units we know
that Planck's constant is such-and-such
joule-seconds we know all these other
ones so let's find out how the second is
defined okay so we can do that by
defining a little bit of code and here
are the define here the defining
equations that we want to solve
okay so I've just basically you know
speed of light has meters and seconds
Plus this number and all those other
numbers I talked about or here too okay
so let's set up the equations and let's
solve them so there is the new
definitions some of which are not new
because the speed of light was already
there but so the ampere is now some huge
rational number
times two physical constants the
elementary charge and cesium hyper spine
hyperfine splitting frequency and the
kilogram one is really horrendous I mean
the kilogram one is almost going off the
screen and depends on three of the
constants and some of them get even
worse of course so maybe this looks a
little less intimidating if you factor
them but it's still pretty intimidating
and if you want to see how bad it gets
so let's just take our old friend the
Joule that should be I think kilograms
meter second meter squared per second
squared and it just gets worse and worse
Tesla's I haven't made a systematic
search to find one that involves all
seven but there must be one so with a
little more effort I could but Tesla is
already pretty bad
okay so there's Tesla involves can't
necessarily see it let me scroll up for
you so these are all consequences of
what was done in May of 2019 I'm perhaps
running a little short of time but I'll
go over this real quickly which is so
something is fundamental as the electron
mass we like to think of it just as a
mass but it can also be expressed in
terms of other physical constants and
the most commonly known and useful one
you know involves the fine-structure
constant the planck constant the Redbird
constant in the speed of light that's
the first expression up here and it just
so happens that the physical constant
entity domain knows about several of
these equivalent forms because we knew
they were going to be useful so we
started adding them so what that is
telling you is that if I take that first
identity for the electron mass it's
equal to this combination of constants
let me pull out the constants from that
and let me find their relative
uncertainties for each of those four
constants okay so Planck constant and
speed of light are exact they have zero
relative uncertainty here's the two the
fine structure in the red burg that I
mentioned didn't have finite uncertainty
now but what this means is that I can
express the
the uncertainty of the mass of the
electron just by normal air propagation
by taking two times the relative
uncertainty of the fine-structure
constant and adding it to the Redbird
constant so there used to be in the old
code data all these complicated cross
correlations and one measurement was
correlated with others the error
propagation has actually gotten much
easier as well so this is really yet
another simplification so here's just a
little summary table the there's an old
row there's a value in terms of
fundamental constant there's an old
relative uncertainty there's a new
relative uncertainty and there's the
cause of that uncertainty so here you
can see there's a case where the
magnetic constant the electric constant
in the vacuum impedance used to be exact
there now uncertain all these others
used to be uncertain they're known so
you're kind of pushing the problem from
one place to another place which I
wasn't expecting when it first came out
so in summary this redefinition actually
in principle affects the unit system
used by almost everyone there
structurally important in eliminating
dependence on sort of artificial human
objects so they provide a consistency
and a universality that makes the system
usable and stable probably from
henceforth most people almost all people
didn't notice this change but because
the Wolfram language does things
symbolically if you use units or
consonants in Mathematica you will be
among the select few who have the
potential to actually notice it I hope
I've convinced you that this change
while the goal is to have it not look
any different was actually a lot of work
to make lawton it not look different but
still be correct in the Wolfram language
so this was about a month of work to
back propagate this all through the good
news being now that it's done it's
pretty much done for all time and those
updates were done with an
month of the redefinition and they were
made available if you're using 12 they
they were automatically pushed to you
via the padlet mechanism the packet
update mechanism so you don't have to do
anything you just started getting them
if you use SI units and I think I'm out
of time
and I know I went through kind of a lot
kind of fast but I hope I at least gave
you some overview of what happened if or
why you should care and that confidence
that whatever it was Wolfram language
and Wolfram Alpha get it correctly thank
you very much
[Applause]